ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
descendre dans la rue chaque samedi et
ce depuis le 14 janvier dernier date
anniversaire de la révolution tunisienne
une jeunesse avide de liberté qui est
prête à affronter les forces de l'ordre
et aller jusqu'au bout de leur combat
pour une refonte du système politique et
que leurs acquis sociaux soit confirmée
par le gouvernement
zaineb est de toutes les manifestations
a 22 ans cette étudiante en sciences
politiques n'hésitent pas à défier
l'autorité au nom de ses idéaux menacée
est arrêté à plusieurs reprises elle
préfère témoigner à visage couvert
nous sommes arrivés à un point où ils
essayent de nous enlever notre liberté
d'expression
seul acquis de la révolution sans parler
des violences policières que nous
subissons à chaque manifestation
il n'hésite pas à infiltrer nos comptes
facebook à se servir de nos photos pour
nous dénoncer publiquement sur les
réseaux de la police nationale moi j'ai
été arrêté récemment qu'un je milite au
sein de l'université
j'ai des amis dont l'un a été arrêté
pour avoir simplement dénoncer ces
violences sur son compte facebook
ces intimidations ne nous font pas peur
et ils peuvent user de toutes les
techniques possibles pour nous arrêter
mais nous la jeunesse tunisienne nous
sommes en ce fruit et rien ne pourra
nous arrêter
tout comme aïn dheb cali a décidé de se
faire entendre
mais contrairement à ceux qui ont choisi
la voie des manifestations lui c'est à
la nuit tombée et face aux forces de
l'ordre qui préfèrent défendre ses
droits
le recours à la violence il le décrit
comme une nécessité
seule alternative pour rendre visible la
jeunesse des quartiers populaires dont
les quartiers populaires les gens n'en
peuvent plus on ne parle plus de
pauvreté mais de faim les gens meurent
de faim ces gens n'hésitent pas à sortir
dans la rue comme on a pu le voir ces
dernières semaines dans de nombreux
quartiers populaires
je fais partie de ces jeunes là je n'ai
pas hésité à sortir et affronté la
police qui a fait preuve de violence
contre nous certains ont même perdu la
vie comme à kasserine il nous matraquent
il nous gaz nous traquent même jusqu'à
chez nous
ce système n'a d'autre réponse que la
violence pour moi les manifestations
sont contre-productives
les vraies actions sont celles
déclenchées dans les quartiers
populaires dès lors que ce mouvement est
emmené dans les rues de la capitale lors
des manifs déclarées et encadrées les
syndicats et partis politiques
n'hésitent pas à se l'approprier et à
l'instrumentaliser ce qui le pousse
automatiquement à l'épuisement
ces tensions entre la police et les
jeunes ne semblent pas daté
d'aujourd'hui elle semble cependant
s'être intensifiées ces derniers mois
par l'inaction du gouvernement occupés à
faire le jeu des alliances partisanes
un constat qui selon le sociologue en
neige lilly a poussé la jeunesse à
chercher des réponses ailleurs pas vu la
réponse de monsieur le chef de
gouvernement dont quelques jours après
la appelé les amateurs de tabac de
quartier et adam
donc il n'est rien dit bon parce qu'il
n'a pas de projet pour les gouvernements
donc durant ces années là c'est dans les
dix 10 ans n'ont pas de vrai projet de
société
là où il ya une partie dédiée aux jeunes
qui lui sert déjà face à des réseaux qui
leur donne des réponses et les eaux de
de clean les réseaux de drogue les
réseaux de prostitution les réseaux de
l'immigration clandestine les deux
hôtels aux listes aussi donc chaque
réseau entre en jeu pour donner des
réponses mais les gens les plus ce sont
les plus touchés par cette crise et
cette compétence délégués des
gouvernements successifs qu'elle ait
choisi la voie des manifestations celle
des actions violentes
la jeunesse tunisienne semble plus que
jamais déterminés à se réapproprier sa
révolution
celle là même qui avait nourri il ya dix
ans les espoirs de tout un peuple